Постачання російського газу:
Роберт Габек планує вводити обмеження
Парламентські вибори у Франції:
Макрон бореться за більшість.
Статус кандидата ЄС для України:
розмова з головою EPP Вебером.
В ефірі «heute journal» з Ханною Ціммерман
та Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Привіт і добрий вечір всім.
Зізнаюся, дещо дивно
у найспекотніший день року
говорити про небезпеку залишитися
з холодними батареями взимку.
Але такі реалії.
Промисловість Німеччини
не втомлюється описувати сценарії жахів
та говорить про загрозу
існуванню цілих галузей економіки.
Міністр економіки також стривожений
скороченням постачання російського газу.
Роберт Габек наразі
розробляє план вимушених заходів
та знову покладає надії на вугілля.
Клаус Бродбек знає більше.
Міністр економіки з партії Зелених, безперечно,
не так уявляв свою політичну діяльність.
Путін скорочує постачання газу -
від Роберта Габека очікують реакцію.
П’ять швидко написаних
сторінок з тривогою про майбутнє.
Від міністра чекають пояснень.
Зараз наш найбільший пріоритет -
це забезпечення наповненості резервуарів до зими.
Ситуація справді серйозна,
для її вирішення федеральний уряд розробить план дій.
Вугільні електростанції мають
виробляти якомога швидше
та більше струму.
Рівень заповненості резервуарів
на початку листопада має становити 90%.
Постачальники отримають
15 млрд кредитних коштів,
щоб мати можливість закупити
достатньо газу, попри зростання цін.
Крім того, нова модель газового аукціону
має винагороджувати
підприємства, які заощаджують газ.
Натомість кліматичні активісти
критикують такий план.
В жодному разі не треба
знову переходити на вугілля.
Це занадто довгий і застарілий процес.
Натомість треба розбудовувати
відновлювані джерела енергії,
це можливо втілити у короткий час.
А тоді треба заощаджувати газ і ми побачимо,
скільки нам ще не вистачає.
Але промисловість Німеччини
і надалі залежить від газу Путіна,
що неабияк дратує.
Ми, безсумнівно, стурбовані тим фактом,
що наша енергетична та газова залежність
справді настільки разюча.
А коли на іншому кінці трубопроводу
сидить той, хто, очевидно,
не підтримує наших поглядів - і поготів.
Крім того, план Габека почне діяти лише взимку,
коли запрацюють німецькі
термінали рідкого газу (ЗПГ).
Тому в парламенті
шукатимуть рішення у старих концептах -
від гідророзриву до ядерної енергії.
Наразі ми імпортуємо
зріджений природний газ,
та правда в тому,
що краще добувати газ самостійно,
аніж фінансувати добування деінде.
А потім також транспортувати його
з іншого куточка планети.
Взагалі атомні електростанції
не вирішать нинішню кризу.
Проте в перспективі - через два-три,
а, може, навіть 5 років,
у разі гострої нестачі енергії такий
варіант мав би право на життя.
Я взагалі не розумію, чому не запустити
ще справні атомні електростанції.
Міністр захисту клімату
обирає згорання вугілля.
Такі погляди на сьогодні.
Добрий вечір, пане Габек.
Добрий вечір, студіє.
Що ж. Найбільший фанат виходу
Німеччини з атомної енергетики -
Володимир Путін.
Замість того, щоб зараз більше
використовувати вугільні електростанції,
чи не було б доцільніше
підʼєднати до мережі німецькі ядерні реактори?
Чи не могло б це стати
нашою рятувальною соломинкою?
Це міркування ми вже перевірили на початку цього року.
Три атомні електростанції зараз функціонують,
і якби ми хотіли б підтримувати їхню діяльність і надалі,
то треба було б заздалегідь замовити паливні елементи,
які ми отримали б
у середині-кінці наступного року.
Тому взимку нас це не врятувало б.
Деякі критики підозрюють,
що Ви, пане Габек,
відмовляєтеся від ядерної енергії тому,
що для Вас і для партії Зелених
це табу, яке ви не хочете порушувати.
Я не знаю, чи це стало б
серйознішим порушенням табу,
ніж те, що я вчиняю сьогодні -
підключення вугільних
електростанцій до мережі.
Наразі я намагаюся
відійти від програми партії
і робити те,
що необхідно для забезпечення
Німеччини енергією.
На атомну енергію довелося б довго чекати.
На прикладі Франції назву
проблеми, які можуть виникнути,
якби ми тривало
споживали атомну енергетику.
Франція має 56 атомних електростанцій, 29 з них
не підʼєднані до мережі,
а інші мають великі проблеми з постачанням.
А все через низький рівень води у річках,
які використовуються для охолодження.
Тож в будь-якому разі я не вважаю атомну
енергію виходом із ситуації.
Натомість я вбачаю рішення
у припиненні спалювання корисних копалин
та у швидкій розбудові відновлюваних джерел енергії.
З того, що Ви, пане Габек, сьогодні говорите,
можна зробити висновок,
що нам не уникнути критичної ситуації взимку.
І що ми тільки можемо спробувати частково покращити
ситуацію.
Чи правильно я Вас розумію?
Це все спекуляції.
Це сценарій, який зараз здійснився на 60%,
бо «Північний потік-1» було зменшено на 60%.
Такий розвиток подій був завжди можливим.
Тому ми заздалегідь готувалися,
щоб бути «озброєними»
настільки, наскільки це можливо.
Ми розбудовували резервуари, ухвалили
Закон «Про прискорення впровадження ЗПГ»,
закуповували газ з інших джерел.
Важливий також Закон
«Про рівень заповнення газових сховищ».
І те, що заповненість сховищ сьогодні
на достатньому рівні - результат політичних рішень.
Наразі ми спостерігаємо за розвитком ситуації.
Варто розуміти, що Путін
поступово буде скорочувати
постачання газу в Європу задля підвищення цін.
І ми мусимо вживати заходів у відповідь.
Наразі Ви застосовуєте
конкретні фінансові стимули
у галузі промисловості і закликаєте інших до цього.
Чидоведеться зрештою
вживати радикальніших дій?
Ми побачимо.
Важливою є тільки
заповненість газових сховищ до зими
на 90%, як того вимагає закон.
Цей відсоток визначився не випадково.
Наразі рівень заповненості - 57%, що досить непогано
для цієї пори року.
Проте і досі є нестача,
яку ми маємо надолужити влітку.
Досягти цього ми можемо шляхом
закупівлі або через ощадливість.
Цим пояснюються наш заклик
і вжиті заходи.
Як-от виведення
з мережі газових електростанцій,
які потрібні для виробництва електроенергії.
Керівник Федерального
мережевого агентства у пʼятницю
повідомив, що навіть із заповненими сховищами
нам не пережити морозну зиму.
Заповнених газових сховищ
вистачить приблизно на два з половиною місяці -
розрахунок відповідно до рівня споживання
газу останніх кількох років.
Так, споживання може зрости.
Тому економія є нашим
реальним виходом із ситуації.
Розрахунки про два з половиною місяці
проводилися без урахування додаткових поставок газу.
А вони у нас будуть.
Через термінали ЗПГ нам постачатимуть газ із Франції,
Бельгії та Нідерландів.
Через Норвегію, Італію газ
надходитиме до Німеччини.
Ми активно працюємо над пошуком
інших шляхів отримання поставок.
А тоді ми побачимо, що ми маємо.
Я говоритиму тільки відверто -
ситуація справді напружена та серйозна.
Якщо зараз проаналізувати актуальне становище,
то чи можна сказати,
що у боротьбі за енергію наразі перемагає Володимир Путін?
Нам всім добре відома тривала залежність
від постачання газу.
І я дуже добре пам’ятаю, як
багато економістів на початку війни
запевняли, що не все так критично
і нам треба негайно відмовитися від російського газу.
Сьогодні я цих людей навіть не чув.
Мабуть, тому, що наразі більшість усвідомлює, що приблизні
розрахунки не мають нічого спільного з реальністю
підприємств або населення.
Тому ті заходи, яких ми вживаємо,
і наш поетапний підхід є правильними.
Зараз ситуація схожа
на змагання з армрестлінгу,
поки що у Путіна рука сильніша.
Але це не означає, що наші зусилля марні.
І наші м'язи зміцняться.
З нами був віцеканцлер та міністр економіки та
захисту клімату Роберт Габек.
Дякую за розмову.
Дякую Вам.
Цей діалог ми записали за 45 хвилин до ефіру.
Наші західні сусіди обрали новий парламент
і перешкоду для президента Еммануеля Макрона,
який для здійснення своїх проєктів зараз мусить
шукати нову більшість.
Адже абсолютної більшості
у парламенті йому досягти не вдалося.
Зрештою насторожує не тільки напружене
економічне становище
та розчарування у французькій політиці загалом.
Ще тривожнішою є низька явка виборців.
Майже дві третини француженок та французів до 17:00
не проголосували.
Репортаж Томаса Вальде.
Навіть після закриття
останньої виборчої дільниці о 20:00
напруга у Франції
не зникла, а навпаки - зростає.
За результатами обчислень телеканалів та
екзит-полів, більшість голосів, а відтак і мандатів,
здобуває президентський блок «Разом».
Однак абсолютної більшості
досягти все ж не вдалося.
Новий лівий альянс Nupes посідає друге місце,
ультраправі – третє.
Ми сподівалися і очікували на більше.
Керувати - означає робити себе вразливим.
Ви повинні обирати та вирішувати,
відмовлятися від деяких речей.
Це означає розчарування.
І ми розчарували певну кількість французів.
Жан-Люк Меленшон не брав участь у цих
виборах,
і все ж таки він може вважати себе переможцем.
Під його керівництвом вперше було створено союз
лівих, соціалістів, комуністів та зелених.
Ліві хочуть завадити політиці Макрона та
вважають себе
досить сильними для цього.
Цей великий прорив прийшов з історії
французьких повстань і революцій, і цей прорив
має обличчя,
і це обличчя нашого колективу.
Однією з причин того, що Франція зіткнулася
з політичним паралічем у парламенті, також є
хороші результати
ультраправих навколо Марін Ле Пен,
яка отримує більше мандатів, ніж будь-коли.
Ми подолали перешкоду, створену нашим
виборчим законом,
який вже застарів, і тепер ми формуємо
дуже потужну групу Національного об'єднання
у Національній асамблеї.
Еммануель Макрон поки що не дав коментарів,
як і потенційні партнери.
Незадовго до того, як проголосувати,
він зустрів хлопчика,
якому залишив автограф на гіпсі.
Але і самого Макрона сьогодні чекав болючий момент.
У Національних зборах Франції фундаментальна
опозиція
з ультралівих та ультраправих незабаром сформує
блок проти політики Макрона.
Як йому вдасться отримати більшість голосів
за свої реформи та проекти у майбутньому,
поки що незрозуміло.
Томасе Вальде в Парижі,
що це означає для президента та його політики?
Чи має він тепер створювати коаліції?
Концепція «кування» швидких коаліцій
не відома у Франції.
Слід розуміти,
що Франція була і залишається суперечливою.
Більшість французів підтримали Макрона,
тепер вони голосують за опозицію та зміцнюють
радикальну опозицію
з ультралівих та ультраправих.
Це унеможливлює проведення Макроном
його політики в Національних зборах.
Йому доведеться шукати нову більшість,
наприклад, для пенсійної реформи,
з якою він боровся на президентських виборах.
Консерватори можуть залишитися,
деякі з них вже висловилися.
Проте їхній лідер каже:
«Ми були і лишаємося опозицією».
Тож буде складно.
Макрону доведеться йти на компроміси,
кооперуватися з іншими партіями.
Ми зможемо краще уявити собі ситуацію,
коли всі голоси вже будуть підраховані.
Дуже дякую, Томасе Вальде.
Огляд ситуації в Україні із вами, Ханно.
Поглянемо на Схід країни,
за який все ще йде запекла боротьба.
Сьогодні Україна знову повідомляє про тяжкий
артилерійський обстріл
російськими військами Луганської області.
Далі на захід поблизу Дніпра, за повідомленнями,
в результаті обстрілу російськими ракетами
вибухнув склад палива.
Після свого візиту на фронт на Півдні країни
президент України Зеленський заявив у
відеозверненні,
що те, що належить Україні, буде повернено.
Партія AfD достроково завершила свою партійну
конференцію в Саксонській Ризі,
після гарячих дебатів щодо європейської політики.
Майже 56 відсотків делегатів проголосували «за».
Дебати щодо резолюції з критикою ЄС,
яку було внесено лідером правоекстремістської
тюрингської AfD Хокке, тривали добрих дві години.
а новообраний дует керівників Хрупалла та
Вайдель
закликав до перегляду резолюції.
Один із делегатів говорив про скасування
подвійного керівництва.
Лісова пожежа поблизу бранденбурзького міста
Троєнбріцен
продовжує поширюватися.
Близько 600 жителів із трьох районів
довелося сьогодні евакуювати у безпечне місце.
Раніше полум'я поширилося на площу приблизно
в 200 гектарів -
переважно через сильний вітер.
Робота з гасіння пожежі ускладнює те, що на
частині території
розміщено боєприпаси.
А трохи більше ніж за 20 кілометрів від цього місця
сьогодні спалахнула ще одна лісова пожежа,
поблизу Білиця.
В інших частинах Європи протягом кількох днів
також було надзвичайно спекотно
і теж виникали катастрофічні лісові пожежі.
На грецькому острові Евбея понад 100
рятувальників
минулої ночі намагалися загасити серйозну пожежу.
В Іспанії також лютують кілька лісових пожеж.
На Північному Заході довелося евакуювати села.
У Наваррі влада назвала ситуацію
«непередбачуваною»
через вітер.
На думку експертів, збільшення кількості теплових
хвиль -
наслідок глобального потепління.
Наскільки повільно може діяти
Європейський Союз,
особливо добре відчувають на собі ті держави,
яким у той чи інший момент було надано так званий
«статус кандидата».
Часто багато років тому.
А далі?
Далі нічого не відбулося.
Виглядає так, що статус кандидата -
швидше глухий кут, ніж шлях до членства в ЄС.
Вочевидь, наступного тижня Україна також набуде
цього статусу кандидата.
Якщо всі 27 нинішніх членів ЄС погодяться.
Хоч як не парадоксально, їм буде легше саме тому,
що, крім очікування, жодних конкретних наслідків,
пов'язаних із цим статусом, немає.
Це просто щось символічне.
Потрібне терпіння,
каже Томас Райхарт.
За тиждень у Німеччині пройде саміт
«Великої сімки»
з підвищеним рівнем безпеки.
У замку Ельмау основну увагу буде приділено
захисту України.
І питання, таке ж просте, як і відкрите:
чи зможе нерішуча Німеччина
утримати Захід разом, щоб кинути виклик Путіну?
Йдеться про те, що Росія
стратегічно шантажує нас у Європі і ми самі
робимо себе вразливими до такого шантажу,
якщо ми не протистоятимемо.
Протидія – це те, що Шольц намагався зробити
у Києві.
Він виступає за статус кандидата в члени ЄС,
але неясно висловився щодо нових постачань
зброї.
Ми також підтримуємо Україну постачанням зброї,
і ми продовжуватимемо це робити доти,
доки Україна потребуватиме нашої підтримки.
Серед іншого Німеччина пообіцяла протитанкові
гаубиці,
ракетні установки та зенітні танки.
Пообіцяла, але ще не виконала цих обіцянок.
Але насправді Україні потрібно набагато більше.
Вона стає нетерплячою,
як і союзники Німеччини.
Досі існує невизначеність щодо того,
що було обіцяно.
Що буде далі? Де воно зараз?
Це можна було б швидко налагодити, якби
канцлер
і міністр оборони публічно заявили:
«Ось те, що нас просили, ось те, що ми обіцяли,
ось те, що ми доставили».
Кільський інститут міжнародної економіки
опублікував у п'ятницю нові дані.
Вони показують, що навряд чи знайдеться інша країна,
де різниця між обіцяною та справді наданою зброєю
була б настільки ж великою, як у Німеччини.
У мене склалося враження, що після рішення
німецького Бундестагу,
де було оголошено, в чому полягає
стратегія наших постачань -
що ми також постачаємо і важке озброєння,
так ось, після цього з'явилася ціла низка
бюрократичних перешкод,
які Міністерство оборони має подолати
якомога швидше.
У травні Шольц був у Оборонному комітеті.
Це була закрита зустріч.
ZDF має доступ до конфіденційного протоколу.
Шольц пояснив, що не існує єдиного принципу
для постачання зброї,
і що він не називатиме такого принципу публічно.
Це також стосується і важкої зброї.
Виключеними для Шольца є
лише сучасні західні бойові танки.
Але це, звичайно, не стосується старих
«Leopard 1» або «Marder».
Це скандал, що у Німеччині є бойові
машини піхоти і навіть більш важкі танки,
які могли б допомогти Україні, де щодня гинуть
люди,
і це також відповідальність,
яку несе канцлер.
Набагато чіткішою є позиція Шольца
щодо статусу України як кандидата у члени ЄС.
Але... така підтримка поки нічого йому не коштує.
Зі зброєю це питання кількох днів чи тижнів;
вступ до ЄС може тривати роки.
З нами зараз Манфред Вебер, лідер
консервативної групи ЄНП
у Європейському парламенті.
Доброго вечора, пане Вебер.
Доброго вечора.
Є кандидати, які залишаються у цьому статусі
роками,
майже десятиліттями, не добиваючись жодного
прогресу.
Що має зробити Україна, щоб цього не сталося
із нею?
Зараз Україна перебуває у стані війни.
Не слід очікувати,
що питання повного членства вирішиться швидко.
Українці знають -
це символічно, але дуже важливо.
Зеленський поставив у європарламенті запитання,
чи варто боротися
І ми відповідаємо: «Так, варто,
варто боротися за свободу і демократичні цінності».
Це те, що станеться цього тижня.
Я радий, що лідери трьох держав -
Драґі, Макрон та Шольц чітко дали це зрозуміти.
Як Україні у цій ситуації допоможе статус кандидата,
які це матиме конкретні наслідки?
На початку війни ми зрозуміли ,
наскільки важливою є мотивація.
Ми були вражені відвагою народу України.
Тому цей символ дійсно важливий.
Однак потрібні і подальші конкретні кроки,
як ви вже повідомляли,
неприпустимо, що обіцяне німцями
так і не надійшло до України.
Зараз на Донбасі вирішується,
чи переможе Путін.
Тому зброя українцям потрібна зараз.
Також ми повинні надати
економічну підтримку.
Навіть у стані війни країна повинна
виплачувати пенсії.
Тож фінансова підтримка
також має велике значення.
Сподіваюсь, що на шляху до повного членства
ми запропонуємо Україні приєднатися
до наших економічних та валютних організацій
і таким чином притягнути інвестиції.
В Україні біля офіційних установ вже повсюди
майорять прапори ЄС.
Якщо поглянути на Зеленського та послухати його
публічні виступи,
важко припустити, що його задовільнить
цей статус кандидата.
Ви часом не недооцінюєте його?
Як швидко Україна отримає перспективу
стати повноправним
членом - залежить від самої України.
Я вів переговори з багатьма політиками
і друзями України і я переконаний:
якщо скоро настане мир, а ми на це сподіваємося,
і стабільність у країні, тоді Україна
буде готовою до внутрішніх реформ
більше, ніж інші європейські країни.
Українці знають, що таке європейські цінності,
адже вони щодня борються за них.
Я бачу в українцях внутрішню силу.
Кожен напад на Україну
може потенційно стати
нападом на кандитата на членство в ЄС.
Це може викликати
величезний тиск громадськості.
Наразі ми це вже переживаємо.
Чи можна собі уявити, що
зрештою Україна потрапить до ЄС швидше,
ніж усі зараз думають?
Я вважаю, це не стільки
питання повного членства.
Ми повинні усвідомити, що Україна веде
нашу боротьбу, нашу боротьбу за свободу.
Якщо Путін захопить Донбас і Київ,
він не зупиниться, а йтиме далі.
Як він і робив останні десятиліття.
Тож Україна вже є частиною
нашої системи цінностей.
Сподіваюся, на зустрічі наступного четверга ми
робитимемо не лише символічні,
а й цілком конкретні кроки до зміцнення
європейської спільноти.
Адже санкції ще досі не одностайні і, наприклад,
вето Орбана може тривати ще довго.
Нам потрібно подбати про захист
Європейського Союзу,
Що, якщо за якийсь час у Білому Домі знову
керуватиме хтось на зразок Трампа, а не Джо Байден?
Європейцям слід захистити себе,
ось що потрібно обговорити на зустрічі і ось чого
я очікую від Німеччини на Франції.
Нам потрібна реформа та зміцнення ЄС.
Однак про те, що нам потрібно реформувати ЄС,
розмови йдуть вже роками.
Чому ми й досі не просунулись?
Чому й досі ухвалення рішень залежить від країн,
на які власне хочуть накласти санкції.
Це ж цілковитий абсурд.
Так, нам слід змінити тактику.
Досі для ухвалення рішень потрібна була
одностайність.
Але світ більше не чекає на європейців,
поки ми об'єднаємось.
Якщо станеться так, що нам не вдасться
дійти згоди
з такими країнами, як Угорщина,
тоді наступний крок нам треба буде робити
без Угорщини.
Ми вже робили так при погодженні євро,
тоді також не всі брали участь.
Я б не хотів чекати на найповільнішого,
Європа повинна мати силу і йти вперед.
Я вважаю, що цю ініціативу повинен взяти
на себе Олаф Шольц.
Чи може Європа зараз прийняти такі країни як
Західні Балкани, Молдову та Україну?
Якщо ми поглянемо, наприклад, на таку країну,
як Молдова
що розміщена між Україною та Румунією.
Це маленькі країни,
якщо вони стануть членами,
для нас це не буде проблемою.
Вони можуть бути для нас збагаченням,
але умовою для цього є внутрішня реформа.
Якщо кожна країна зможе
заблокувати певні рішення, виникне ризик,
що Європа стане неспроможною діяти.
Якщо ж глянути далі, в напрямку Китаю, Тайвані
та Африки, то ми
розуміємо, що ЄС не в найкращій формі.
Ми беззахисні у світі бурь, нам слід добре підготуватися
до завдань, які чекають нас найближчими роками.
Дякую, Манфреде Вебер.
Тепер до спортивних новин.
Так, і до переможців.
Вже втретє їм це вдалось -
клуб «Альба Берлін» знову став
чемпіоном Німеччини з баскетболу.
Берлінці впевнено обіграли ФК «Баварія Мюнхен»
з рахунком 96-81.
Це вже водинадцяте «Альба Берлін»
здобув титул чемпіона.
У «Формулі-1»
чемпіон світу Макс Ферстаппен
взяв головний приз Канади,
на другому місці - водій «Феррарі» Карлос Сайнц.
Мік Шумахер, який прагнув стати
чемпіном «Формули =1»
протягом своєї кар’єри,
вибув передчасно через
дефект на транспортному засобі.
До тенісу: поразка світового чемпіона.
Данііл Медвєдєв несподівано програв фінал
тенісного турніру в м. Галле
супернику з Польщі Губерту Гуркачу.
Той переміг явного фаворита у
двох сетах з рахунком 6:1 і 6:4.
Рівно через тиждень тут відбудеться
пряма трансляція саміту Великої сімки
в баварських Альпах,
але і до того буде багато цікавого.
Ось огляд «heute jornal» від Скарлетт Штернберг.
Як виглядатимуть промислові
майданчики майбутнього?
І як впоратися з економічними кризами?
До Дня промисловості політики, економісти
та науковці з понеділка
працюватимуть у Берліні над
нагальними питаннями.
У вівторок у Берліні відкриється
Міжнародна Аерокосмічна виставка (ILA).
Найбільше авіаційне шоу в Європі
вперше після двох років
відбудеться наживо.
У програмі: деяка військова техніка
та демонстрації польотів літаків «Eurofighter».
У середу федеральний канцлер зробить заяву уряду.
Напередодні саміту ЄС наприкінці
цього тижня йтиметься між іншим
про перспективу
вступу до ЄС кількох держав.
З четверга
глави європейських держав та урядів
займуться питанням кандидатства України.
Частина країн ЄС все ще
налаштовані скептично.
Крок до статусу кандидата
має передусім символічний ефект.
Партія лівих з п'ятниці обиратиме на з'їзді партії
свого голову.
Знову передбачено подвійне керівництво.
Також балотується попередній голова
Джанін Вісслер.
Яка ж погода очікує нас після цих спекотних
вихідних?
На північному сході
та в центрі завтра прогнозуємо зливи.
На півдні вдень після обіду
окремі грози, місцями з градом
та сильний дощ.
Температура сягатиме від 17 до 24°,
на півдні 24-33°.
У наступні дні буде дуже сонячно,
лише на півдні та південному заході
час від часу зливи та гроза.
Максимальна
температура складе від 19 до 32°.
Таким був наш світ цієї неділі,
дякую, що Ви були з нами.
Бажаємо Вам приємного вечора.
До зустрічі завтра в ефірі.